things getting of course very tense with
North Korea right yeah yeah I've heard
the latest today I know you're hissing I
don't know what you're hissing there are
so many things to hiss there just the
concept of war I don't know
today president Trump warned that if
North Korea does not stop escalating its
nuclear program quote they will be met
with fire and fury like the world has
never seen
yeah yeah then Melania said don't worry
he says that's me every night and
nothing ever happened
[Applause]
that's my Trump you know he's getting
ready for bed he's coming that's milani
he's coming toward you see and that's
his move that's it that's also my
signature movement all right I'm coming
baby look like a bat coming in for a
landing
yeah it's getting weird this week
president Trump plans to travel to New
York he's gonna go to New York
plants need some pizza then deport the
Statue of Liberty that's what again
moving crowds a little tent still it's
gonna be fine don't worry about it
hey there's a new online quiz that tells
you if you would be allowed to enter the
u.s. under President Trump's immigration
policies yeah
consists of a single question are you a
swimsuit model
get in it's gonna be fine it's gonna be
fine I'm gonna we're in it together yeah
I see see see the crowd already just
relaxing hello
North Korea's stuff is all behind us now
because I made a swimsuit joke
hey this interesting political experts
say that many members of Congress are
preparing for a Mike Pence presidency
yeah they're preparing they're preparing
by binge watching The Handmaid's Tale
is interesting a new study came out a
study of chain restaurants and it found
that the Cheesecake Factory
serves the unhealthiest food yeah yeah
when asked for comment that CEO said
folks it's called The Cheesecake Factory
right we're not hiding anything even if
it didn't have cheesecake in the name
you should never eat it a fat no no it's
it's the two unhealthiest word jam
together might as just well throw death
in there too
let's go to the Cheesecake Factory
there's a rumor that Cynthia Nixon from
Sex in the City may run for governor of
New York yeah yeah her strategy is to
reach out to low-income Miranda's
without alienating wealthy Samantha's
that's the economy
trust me that's really good it's very
hard to come out and tell people that's
North Korean thing yeah yeah anyway I
[Laughter]
think this whole situations been hardest
on you and me I really do think of
anyone out in the world that you would
make yeah I think worldwide people right
now we're thinking about the comedian's
hey this is interesting McDonald's if
it's not it's just the next joke
well the important thing is I'm having
fun
McDonald's plans to nearly double its
restaurants in China double the number
of restaurants in China McDonald's yeah
in other words China is getting rid of
its one-child policy and it's one Qin
policy hi everybody
you